hi i'm steve clemons and today i have
two questions first is nato succeeding
in walking the fine line between
defending ukraine and direct
confrontation with russia and later in
the show what's going on in president
zelinski's mind these days let's get to
the bottom line
one of the major effects of the war in
ukraine is that it has revived nato just
a couple of years ago the alliance of
western countries was being bashed on a
daily basis by former u.s president
donald trump who constantly said that
america pays too much to defend europe
but now the u.s government has poured
billions into ukraine and president joe
biden has asked for another 33 billion
dollars the flow of weapons from the
west to ukraine is the biggest supply
since world war ii but all of this also
comes at the expense of europe's
stability which was the point of
creating nato in the first place moscow
is now demanding that nato stop
supplying weapons to ukraine and stop
trying to recruit more eastern european
countries to the pro-western alliance so
what should we expect in the coming
months especially as the war drags on
with no end in sight today we're talking
with the deputy secretary general of
nato murcia giona a diplomat and
politician from romania who served as
his country's foreign minister and
president of the senate deputy secretary
general thank you so much for joining us
i want to ask you right now as we watch
the intensity of fighting uh in ukraine
we see this crisis we see the escalation
and rhetoric from people like russian
foreign minister sergey lavrov is nato
ready for a potential escalation if this
war spills into nato territory how will
nato respond
we are indeed entering a decisive stage
of the war that russia has waged against
ukraine in the donbas in the south
so we anticipate the next few weeks to
be really decisive even if the war could
really drag on for a longer period of
time
for the time being other than the the
rhetoric
which we condemn
by
russian leaders we do not see
in military terms indications for russia
willing or able
to escalate
the situation with nato
probably the fact that nato has been
mobilizing
significant additional forces on the
eastern flank
that we're activating for the first time
in history the
defense plans for for the eastern flank
countries
um is a significant symbol of deterrence
and strength of the alliance so the war
probably will rage on even more
intensely with even more casualties with
more sacrifice
but at this time in point we do not see
a risk of escalation between russia and
nato and we are also trying to avoid an
escalation between nato and russia
look i cannot imagine how complex your
job is there are a lot of members of
nato there are new ones like finland and
sweden that are talking about joining
that's still on the table for other
states as well
i think before this crisis nato was kind
of taken for granted i think people felt
nato's there but now we see a new
purpose we see a revived sense of
purpose of that alliance how healthy is
it tell us about the inner workings that
you have to deal with every day with
these different delegations different
militaries i just love to give our
audience a sense of the inner picture
i i've been in this in this game and
this line of war for many years as you
as you said steve i've never seen nato
so united i've never seen a common sense
of purpose
and in a way it is this war that that
russia wages against ukraine galvanized
in a way nato but also public opinions
something that i think is just
extraordinary is that only the fact in
which governments u.s government
england uk romania whatever nato ian
stalterberg myself were reacting to this
crisis in a very professional and united
way
but our public opinions our businesses
when russia
waged a cyber attack against a ukrainian
satellite providing telecom and internet
to ukraine all of a sudden an american
private company came to the rescue we
are seeing ngos raising money for for
for ukrainian refugees so what i think
is just remarkable is not only the
political or military side of nato
re-galvanized but our democracies our
public opinions our businesses our
citizenry and this is something i
believe is nothing short of formidable
and we hope to keep this momentum going
forward has there been a kind of i don't
know how to put it otherwise than a kind
of polite surprise at the resilience of
of ukrainians after this invasion uh a
polite surprise about vladimir
zelinski's
resilience in this moment and his
leadership
we have been training as nato or nato
countries individually the armed forces
of ukraine since 2014 after the illegal
annexation of crimea and the occupation
of the eastern part of the donbass
so we knew
that ukraine as a military
has been transformed into a quasi-nato
standard
while russia has remained as a
post-soviet army
and i think that the difference in
command and control in in in the quality
of
of leadership in the military was not
something that surprised us
but i think everything was surprised
by the immense bravery of ukrainian
people as a whole beyond the military
the fantastic administ communication
skills and harrys by president zaleski
and his team so this is where i say we
were pleasantly surprised by the resolve
by the
level of sacrifice by the level of of of
ambition to defend their land this is
where we're surprised but in terms of
the transformation of the ukrainian
armed forces we are not surprised
because they are already a modern army
and with the support they get from nato
allies they are becoming even more
affordable formidable as we speak and
this is our intention to continue to
help ukraine in his just fight against
uh the aggression of russia
i'm going to take the liberty of asking
you a question not about nato i mean you
and i have known each other for many
many years and you're a leading uh face
of of you know romanian civil society
and civic engagement you've been
president of the senate their foreign
minister ambassador there i'm just
interested in how this crisis has
changed how an average romanian citizen
feels about their place because they're
pretty close to russia they're also part
of nato but does it change the internal
dynamic of identity and how romanians
feel in this moment
you know many of the younger generations
were taking democracy and freedom for
granted in a way
because you're part of nato because
you're part of the european union
because we're part of the western family
of nations
but i think this war is was also a
brutal wake-up call
for many of our citizens not only in
romania
i think all the countries in the eastern
flank but even more importantly
for countries in western europe
germany look at the sea change of the
public attitude and the strategic
culture in berlin which is absolutely
formidable
look at the change in italy look at the
change in france in the us in in in
canada in the uk
so i think for all of us newcomers into
nato like my country older members of
nato from the very beginning
we were basically
in in face of the
reality and the brutal reality that war
is possible in europe something we
considered will never happen again after
the second world war and look war is
back in europe so either way this is a
drama for the ukrainians and for europe
but it's also a fantastic wake-up call
as short re renowning our vows with
democracy and nato and security and
that's how my fellow romanians feel we
are so lucky to be nato we are so lucky
to be in the eu
and we have the obligation to help
ukrainians down down
their legitimate way to join us in
european union let me just ask you
finally mr deputy secretary general and
first thank you for your service and
what you're doing and for joining us
today
um i know in november that you were
hoping that the russians would agree to
an honest dialogue to defuse tensions
that they would go there we haven't seen
that take part i don't know our way out
of this but one of the obvious questions
is is this now a permanent new cold war
where we have essentially another
dark line
across nations and their futures as
we've seen how sanctioned russia is
today we see other complicit nations
with with what russia is doing in
belarus and others you lived on the
other side of that wall uh with the west
from the west when you grew up and so
you know a lot about walls and you know
a lot about bleakness when it comes to
futures what is your sense uh what does
your gut tell you is this something now
we're going to be at for decades ahead
or do you see any off ramp in the near
term where we can avoid that dark future
of another harsh line between russia and
its interests and the rest of the world
it is no mystery that
the
russia
nato russia
america russia and
europe europe relationship is the lowest
point
in many decades
that's a fact
and as long as russia will continue to
be an aggressive
player will occupy its neighbors
illegally of course the relationship
will stay at very low level
at the same time we are not in the
business of ruling out
a future relationship with russia which
is a big country a great people a great
history great culture
so when russia will realize that this is
not the way to approach
european security and to engage its
neighbors and and its partners in europe
i do not rule out a moment in time i
don't know when but the moment in time
when things will if not come back to
normal
when some form of of of dialogue with
russia would resume but as long as they
occupy uh territories they behave like
they behave
will be very difficult for us to to do
that but again we are not ruling out
that in the future and a moment
of russia's choosing in a way when they
change course
i i know that we'll be ready to
re-engage with them once they'd be
changing the way in which they approach
uh security politics and also values and
this is something very important for
nato
deputy secretary general of nato merced
giona thanks so much for your candid
thoughts and joining us today
now we turn to the issue of what's going
on inside the head of ukrainian
president vladimir zelinsky these days
and we're fortunate to be talking with a
journalist who shadowed zolensky's team
for two weeks and interviewed him in his
compound in kiev
simon schuster is a correspondent for
time magazine and his cover story comes
out this week how zelensky leads simon
it's an incredible uh bit of reporting i
had chills reading what you were sharing
about being with uh ukraine's president
under extraordinary circumstances you
were there i guess my first comment to
you is you know
share with our viewers right now what
the sense of that is and i would also
just ask you as a you know uh fellow in
this how have how has your reporting in
this incredible let me put here you know
and time magazine says this incredible
document not shared with the russians
his habits and where he's going
um
so yeah as you said i've spent about two
weeks
um
basically with the
the president's team at the presidential
compound um he hasn't made any secret of
where he is that's one thing that that
really surprised me from the beginning
of the invasion
on day two
he posted a video of himself
standing outside in the courtyard
of the presidential compound there in
kiev on bancova street
but when i saw that video i was like
what he's still there what does he do
how is he not run
but that was the message of the video
that
he is not running he's not going away uh
there's been no secret as to where he is
um and
you know the his message
explicitly and implicitly to the
russians is you know come and get me i'm
i'm not going anywhere
um so so my my uh request to to him and
his team was to
uh go in there and essentially um see
what their
life has been like right how they
experienced this war um and and they
allowed me to do that
you know you interviewed him and you
knew him when he was a comedian uh which
was fascinating bit of background that
you had with him personally what are
some of the changes you've seen
since the invasion of ukraine and since
his remarkable leadership uh in these
horrible circumstances
yeah i i've been lucky enough to know
him um for about three years i i first
profiled him for a piece in time
magazine at the time not a cover story
when he ran for president in 2019 it was
a bit of a quirky story
not not a
a huge one as far as the global news
agenda a comedian running for president
and uh you know emerging in the in the
polls is the likely winner
so i went to kiev at the time and i met
him um backstage of his comedy show
which was kind of doubling as his
campaign
uh
platform his campaign rally um it was a
a variety show in kiev where he was the
star there was singing and dancing and
and uh sketch acts and things like that
um so of course you know the zelinski i
met backstage of that show
uh was a very different person than the
one that we've seen you know in this
invasion at the time he was
quite naive about politics generally
he was very optimistic and confident in
his ability to
you know find a way to uh
strike a peace deal or reach reach some
kind of accord with vladimir putin in
russia
and indeed he tried to do that for the
first two years of his tenure as
president after he won those elections
um
he grew more and more disillusioned with
the possibility of doing that in those
two years
and then you know since the invasion
it's it's a
a very different man he's he's grown a
lot
more um
hard
uh
tougher you could say
um in some ways much more confident in
his um
his own sense of his
his role as a leader
he doesn't doubt himself as much as i
saw him uh doing
in earlier interviews um so this this
interview for this cover was my my
fourth interview with him over his
career as a politician
um and and the changes have been you
know pretty interesting to observe and
and dramatic in this pretty
extraordinary career he's had we know
that ukraine is a divided country or was
a divided country in some ways what have
been those that sort of thought they
were tilting wanted to tilt more towards
russia have they been moved by seeing
this invasion are they impressed now
with zielinski have you talked to people
that might not all have been in lockstep
but before president zielanski before
this invasion
um yes
i i don't think uh
honestly
that
um group of voters um will make up a
significant block you know at the end of
this war i think the invasion has
absolutely disgusted everyone
i spoke to who may have been more open
to
[Music]
some kind of restoration of normal
relations with russia in the past
that's all over you know there was maybe
a constituency um that you could say was
pro-russian um before this invasion
there was certainly a significant party
in the parliament of ukraine that
represented um in some ways russia's
interests or acted as a proxy or a
stand-in for for russia and its talking
points politically in ukraine um that
party is is essentially gone as a as a
political player um i don't think it has
a power base anymore i mean think about
it so russia promised or claimed that it
was invading ukraine in order to save
the people of eastern ukraine
the regions of the country where uh you
know people say
they're they're more kind of
russia-leaning voters but what's
happened to those regions they've been
totally decimated by this war thousands
of people have been killed by this
invasion who were supposedly you know
the the the electorate of the
pro-russian forces in the ukrainian
parliament so there's just there's not a
leg to stand on politically after this
conflict during this conflict for any
politician in ukraine who says um you
know let's let's get along with russia
and let's make nice and let's let's uh
try to try to you know follow some of
vladimir putin's ideas about what
ukraine needs to look like those days
are over i don't think there's any
realistic scenario where
uh russia has a kind of political
vehicle for for pursuing its interests
inside ukrainian politics after this is
done now you know you're a real reporter
you're in the middle of it you can you
can take first-hand reporting but we're
seeing the signals and i'm interested in
information and what the north star is
in a mo at a moment when uh there is
there are major efforts of
disinformation out there but but when
you're in the middle of this and you see
you know president zolensky wanting to
raise the hopes of people how do you
yourself advise people who are looking
in this to be able to separate fact from
fiction
um
[Music]
that's that's tough i mean i report what
i uh hear from reliable sources and know
to be true
again i'm not sure it's it's my uh role
to educate your viewers or or my readers
in media literacy um i i i hope they
read and watch reliable sources of
information
um you know i i think uh yeah every side
in in a war
generally tries to win over the hearts
and minds of of uh the other side and
the global community that's watching the
conflict um president zielenski has
certainly devoted
a lot of his time you know when i was
there
hanging around the presidential compound
you know i'd say the bulk of his time is
is devoted to what you might call um you
know communication strategy right giving
speeches writing speeches
um meeting with foreign leaders
addressing you know various venues from
uh
the parliament of south korea
right i mean the world bank
he spoke at the grammy awards um so all
of these things you could perhaps
cynically classify as part of the
information front in this in this
conflict but yes he's he's trying to get
his message across um as as forcefully
as he can because he knows that his
ability to do that his ability to grasp
and hold the world's attention
uh and maintain the support of the world
uh will in many ways determine whether
his country lives or dies
and he's been doing a pretty good job at
keeping the world engaged and and
supportive of ukraine um does he worry
that that he may not be on the cover of
time magazine um as frequently as he
needs to be to to maintain attention
yeah that's definitely a concern he has
um the last time we sat down um i think
it was april 19th
he
asked me
whether i felt that the uh the world's
attention was was flagging um
so it's clearly a concern you know he's
he said that uh
he he thinks a lot about how
um
people outside of ukraine perceive this
conflict uh understand this conflict
mostly through social media
uh through outlets like you know
instagram on their instagram feeds
uh and he
expressed this concern that you know the
war has been so horrifying to to observe
to watch you know as he put it there's a
lot of blood and there's a lot of
emotion
uh and he
felt the concern that eventually
people would just start to turn away
because it was just you know unbearable
to watch it's just this constant stream
of
of of pain atrocities you know
bombings cities and communities being
destroyed
and he was concerned that the
international community and and uh
international leaders would just
eventually not not be able to to uh take
it anymore would essentially turn away
close their eyes um and that he said you
know is a real danger for ukraine you
know another thing that he shared with
you um and it was so interesting to read
it in such raw form that he himself
worries that his military will be
crushed by the russian military so much
larger does he think that the supplies
and systems that are coming in
can
preclude that fear that his own military
will be crushed by the russians
i i think broadly you know the sense i
got from him and and his closest
advisors
is they're very confident in in their
own ability to win i mean they
understand the risks they understand the
risks of russia dropping you know some
enormous bomb on the compound where they
live and work they understand the risks
that their armies will be um surrounded
and and
partly or completely defeated uh in the
battle for eastern ukraine that just is
ongoing now uh the level of morale in
society and in the military is extremely
high it's extremely high among zolensky
and his advisors
i think as a corollary to that there
isn't a huge enthusiasm for
uh
jumping headlong into peace talks with
russia on the ukrainian side so i i do
think that uh and zalensky said this in
no uncertain terms that
uh the outcome of this current battle
for eastern ukraine will in many ways
shape uh our dialogue at the negotiating
table uh to put that more simply um you
know let's let's see how well we can do
in pushing the russians back militarily
uh and depending on the outcome of those
battles we'll we'll see where we stand
on the negotiating table well we're
going to have to leave it there time
magazine correspondent simon schuster
fresh back from kiev extraordinary
reporting i highly recommend people take
a look at how zelinski leads it's the
cover story of time magazine
right now uh thank you so much for
joining us
thank you
so what's the bottom line regardless of
what you think of the war in ukraine you
really have to hand it to president
zielinski he's a guy who started out as
a comic until three years ago and now
he's looked upon by his partners in
america and europe as a kind of
churchillian figure keeping hope alive
even in the darkest days but here's the
rub this war has gone from a sprint to a
marathon and the world is a massive case
of add or attention deficit disorder so
what happens when people start skipping
over the ukraine videos on their phones
is it game over for zolensky and his
vision for ukraine does zelinski have to
be the entertainer indefinitely or will
the west find the resolve to commit
itself for the long haul no matter what
the future of what it means to be a
sovereign state is what is at stake and
that's the bottom line
[Music]
you